[Music]
alright fellas do you want me to hold in
these that I looked in my hands it's
like a it's like a school photo so the
one thing I'm addicted to is white dress
shirts I don't know when I started
hoarding white shirts but I think it
happened like a decade ago after I sort
of started cycling through all the
colors and realizing that white just
sort of felt right for me the best thing
about it is it makes you look polished
dressed up I tend to like to wear kind
of suit jackets and ties with jeans so
it's kind of the perfect foundation for
any jacket or time you can get them as
little as $20 at Uniqlo you can also pay
$500 or more if you're going to like do
ro or sailor on this one happens to be
from costs it cost about $90 I think it
looks a lot like some of those higher
end ones but certainly doesn't carry the
same price tag they have a little
elastin in them which not only makes
them easy to move around in but it also
helps them from wrinkling so much so you
don't have to like be ironing it every
single time I'm also like of a
generation of Reservoir Dogs and Gattaca
and all of these movies where it was
like the white shirt was the anchor to
this future cool badass look so when I
wear one I too am futuristic and cool
and badass today we're gonna talk about
the Chelsea boot I have no idea
can't you guys throw that like here
somewhere you definitely stay in the
Chelsea boot in the pages of GQ you've
probably seen it on any number of rock
stars or otherwise famous or stylish
people I am NOT a rock star or famous
but when I finally did try it and I like
it as it dresses up any outfit like
usually I wear this black t-shirts black
jeans with basic white bands and it
looks kind of sloppy but you put these
on you can go to like Ruth's Chris or
some really nice Steakhouse this is New
Republic Marc McNary these are 99 bucks
and they don't look like they're 99
bucks super easy I mean they obviously
slip right on very comfortable there is
no real break-in process they're
probably the most comfortable shoes
another thing I love about these Chelsea
boots no laces so very easy slide on and
off first thing I do when I get home
every day from work is I take my pants
off but you can't take your pants off
but I think it shoes off and these are
great seams slide right off the next
thing you know you're on your couch with
no pants off why white jeans I'd like
own some blue jeans but none of them
make me feel quite as happy as white
jeans Dale I think you even liked
reading GQ in high school I was like oh
man white jeans I want to give that a
spin they're like a little off-center
and you're only supposed to wear them
between Memorial and Labor days I think
that's all a bunch of horseshit it's a
fun way to look a little unusual while
still wearing a pretty normal piece of
clothing so I like to wear all white I
like to wear a white t-shirt with white
jeans it looks a little weird and people
do a slight double take but I'm kind of
into that and then you can really wear
any shoes you want I generally stay away
from white shoes because you don't want
to look like mr. clean or a nurse
although shout out to mr. clean and
nurses everywhere these are from Uniqlo
from there you line that's a French
designer and Christophe lemare fresh out
of the box I cut them a little bit at
the bottom so they hit the spot I want
but I generally iodide I feel weird
about tailoring your jeans so in kind of
addictions this double-breasted blazer
which is from engineered garments the
thing that I really love about double
wrestle Blazers is the silhouette is
just so much cooler I think than the
single breasted Blazers so I really like
to let mine hang loose but it's just way
more advanced takes it to a new level
the rule of thumb with double-breasted
blazer buttons is you need to have at
least two on each side I like to button
the bottom one a little unorthodox but
you get a nice little roll on your lapel
here and it just looks chill and it's a
little unexpected if you're unfamiliar
with a double-breasted blazer you're
intimidated by it you're getting like
weird Wall Street vibes relax there's a
lot of really casual ones out there and
if you wear it casually it looks casual
so don't overthink it if you're shopping
the one thing that you need to keep in
mind is
has to have a peak love how it looks
sharper it's cooler
it looks more interesting when the
colors pop if you find a double-breasted
blazer with a notch lapel just keep
walking do not buy it trust me
it's funny because me talking about the
black Levi's Jack is a little bit like
me talking about why I wear my skin
black trucker Jack is what I wear when I
just want to like get out of the door
knowing I'm gonna feel like myself I
have no idea when I got my first denim
jacket I really don't I have had them
for many years going back to the mid
2000s for sure there's a store in
Berkeley California called slash denim
it's a Levi's specialist she has really
specific ideas about the best stuff over
the years that Levi's has ever released
and when something great comes out she
just buys a shitload of it are you
always by a trucker jacket when I go
there and I haven't been there in five
years so that's why it's been a while
I've been craving a new one when I think
of charcoal jackets I definitely think
of Martin Sheen and Terrence Malick's
Badlands you know they're on the run and
he's got on jeans and a white t-shirt
there's a really famous still photo from
the set of him like with his hands up
looking cool in the trucker jacket it's
just like classic Americana if we're
gonna get really terrence malick there
should be like some quiet music and just
like a shot of my shoelaces moving if
somebody said to me I don't feel like I
can pull off a denim jacket I would say
that's absolutely true as long as you
think you can't pull it off just do it
this nestle thing is pulling it off you
just do it and then it's done then it's
pulled